Many, many lessons ago we helped Grant choose between three different brands of
glasses cleaning solution to sell along with his wiper sets. One brand that
seemed like a pretty good option gave us this equation, y equals 10x plus 150.
In this equation, x stands for the number of gallons of cleaning solution that
Grant orders, y is equal to the total cost of the order. The solution cost $10
per gallon. And there is a flat delivery fee of $150 added on, regardless of
how much solution was ordered. Before, Grant decided how much solution to
order, so what x should be based pretty much just on how much he wanted or
needed. When we plug that number in for x, the function would output how much
it would cost him. However, Greg's being a bit more strict with his budget
these days. And instead of doing things the old way, he wants to set aside a
certain amount of money to spend on cleaning solution. That means that now, we
probably need to switch up our equation a bit. He's going to want to calculate
the amount of solution ordered based on the amount of money spent. Since now,
amount ordered depends on money spent, let's switch up our variable names. If
we want x to equal the total cost of the order and y to equal the amount of
cleaning solution ordered, what will our equation look like now? Remember that
all of our quantities are still related to each other in the same way, we're
just changing their names.